I just never understood repopulation if
the world ends let it end all I can hear
is I don't think you're attractive I'm
Katie and I'm Brad and this is the end
of the world we work together we've
known each other for exactly an hour if
I had 24 hours left to live I would
definitely go BASE jumping I would just
go to all the most expensive restaurants
and order a bunch of stuff and dine and
dash that's a great one I would probably
be naked in public a lot I don't know if
I would say like Dan but if I were to be
trapped in a pack elliptic bunker with
him I'd make it work I think Dave
wouldn't last five minutes in the
apocalypse would you repopulate with me
123 yes yes you waited look at it let's
just put it out together this look it on
me
oh yeah that does that's not good we're
gonna be spending a lot of time together
so I thought it best to speak to you
like this the whole time can you pick
the multi-tool cuz she's a smart
strong-willed woman I'm a practical lady
this is good kids I feel like this will
definitely make me want to kill myself
yeah that was the right choice this is
good I feel so comfy it'll be fun to
make little like signs and keep track of
our time here oh uh yeah I'm gonna call
them currency what a sombrero that's
freaky I'm in the last three days over
let's brush our teeth let's have sex and
die I hate when people are sad so at any
time I could just pull out the sombrero
and it's gonna get a laugh right working
right now our bunker would be like a
universe it'd be really pretty what do
you think your role would be first one
dead eatin you it's here to me it's the
apocalypse it's this megaphone how long
will it last
you